perfect
all right um
[Music]
so maybe we will about two more minutes
before getting started
but um so we all are on the same page um
what we're going to be talking about for
the next 45 minutes to an hour is um
hubert um and
about like a month back we did a paper
reading on wave 2 2 and um
hubert sort of builds on top of of wave
to a 2.0 and um you know um adds like
better um spoken language understanding
uh so to speak
and um we'll essentially be like
reading the paper um for the next 45 to
um 45 minutes to one hour um
the session is supposed to be like as
much uh discussion as possible the
slides that you see on the screen are
just like placeholders and essentially
for all of us to just talk about um uh
what's on the site so feel free to like
popcorn style anytime just like jump in
and and be like hey what's what's
happening here or or you know share your
thoughts about what you uh what you
think about the paper itself
um
and um
like throughout um the way we sort of go
about it is is um the way
that i've structured it is is that we'll
first talk about the main motivation of
the of the approach itself then we sort
of um
walk through the entire framework of
hubert um and um then essentially work
our way to the
um
to the results and then like just just
discuss how um things
are
um currently and like what can be
improved in the um
in the overall
um framework meant um you know
spoken about by um the authors
um about hubert
um does that sound fair enough
sounds good to me
perfect
cool so i i think we're at like um uh
five or five park so um i think it's a
it's a it's a good time to get started
um as well um i'll just quickly share
the link to the slides for those of you
who are
um on phone and want to just
look at the slides parallelly
so that will be
discord
um it's shared in the ml for audio study
group
perfect
um so so all right so so um
one of the first things which i um um
which i kind of like
the first observation that i had when i
was reading through the hubert paper was
um um was was that they they pretty much
used the overall design of wave to work
too uh in itself and then they
essentially change
the way the model learns um speech um
representation units right like so so so
the slus uh in the sense um if we if we
just quickly take a step back and
remember like how we have to wait two
was we have two had the second entire
quantization
uh module which would um learn um these
these spoken um um these speech
representations uh and
you know then sort of use those
um later on for for different different
downstream tasks right um and this was
done via like a gumball soft max which
essentially takes like a continuous
um
um like a like a continuous variable and
then like creates like discrete sort of
chunks out of it right and
like everything was essentially learned
on the go
um
and and
the reason why it worked uh
fantastically is um is because like the
model um essentially has um like
access to quite a lot of pre-training
data so it can quite easily learn on the
go but the reason why it's not that
that's suitable for for a lot of tasks
is that just in like pre-training itself
just the parameters of like gumball um
soft max is
are like quite um
quite nuanced uh meaning that they are
they are very temperament and they need
to be tuned um and you know just a
slight change in the parameters could
result in like um the
the model just not learning those
uh representations in the first place
right and um that's where like hubert
comes in um
and um and and hubert essentially um
provides an alternative approach to
learn these um representation units
right so
um the three problems that the that the
authors kind of like start off with is
that um uh like the the first one is
that there are multiple sound units in
each input utterance right so each each
utterance can ha can be like um can be
like multiple sound units plugged
together right um and uh
because this is just like
the model is supposed to just learn from
the audio itself or like some
representation of the audio itself um it
means that there is also no like text or
like some sort of lexicon available for
the model to
um
learn with as well right so so the model
just has access to raw audio waveforms
um and and the model has to make sense
of
what those audio waveforms are um
without the corresponding transcription
of it um this makes the task like
considerably difficult because um well
now you don't have anything to map those
audios to
right um
and uh the the third problem is that uh
sound units have like variable and
depending upon whichever language you're
talking about even in like english
itself um there's no such thing as like
every 20 milliseconds would be uh would
be say for example a new sound unit
within a
um
um
um
within an audio waveform right so um so
um
these like sound units itself
there's no like one size fits all um
kind of set up wherein like you can you
can just like um
take a snippet off the audio waveform
itself and say that hey this is a sound
unit right and this corresponds to say
the sound um a or like b or whatever
right so um these are the three key
problems um
that that are there wave to work 2.0 um
solves or like attempts to solve this uh
we are the whole quantization approach
and and like having the
the contrastive loss and the diversity
loss um
in in its pre-training criteria and cuba
takes a slightly separate approach uber
takes um an approach which is more
bird-like so
it essentially
uses the mass language modeling criteria
to learn these um
speech representations
um
so i'm i'm just gonna take a quick pause
and see if if um anyone has any any
thoughts on the overarching um
problem that
uh hubert is trying to solve or wave to
work 2.0 try to solve
and
like feel free to just like unmute
yourself and and share your thoughts
all right um but it's all right we can
we can we we can also share our thoughts
later on as well um
no
i want something like a very small thing
sure
i know that i'm not the speaker or the
expert but i i always have this feeling
like um
you know speech and audio is a domain
where noises noise and the diversity of
the you know signal is more
uh
compared to text where text is more
standardized
that is it also another challenge for um
the this masked speech
modeling right perfect and that's that's
actually a brilliant uh question so um
you're actually correct like in case of
text text is like really low dimensional
right so text is just like actually it's
just like um one dimensional so you just
have some characters sort of
um
placed in together with each other so
it's it's like for for a world-like
model to actually understand the
semantics it's uh it's actually quite
easy if you if you throw enough um
you know text added um in case of audio
um there are like multiple things which
matter so um
people like speak in different way um
generally right so like no two people
have like the exact same way of
pronouncing
like pronunciating um each and every
um phoneme so to speak right so um one
of the things which which is in which is
an issue um largely is um
when you when you train uh
when you when you use like mass language
modeling sort of a criteria for um
for these
uh
speech representational units um then
these speech representational units
would differ from like one audio file to
the other right so what you um what you
seek from like either the quantization
step or from the clustering step which
we will um cover in a bit is that they
understand the broad patterns of these
um you know consonants or vowels that
are being spoken at the at the moment
and uh
learn to distinguish between white noise
pauses or or just noise in general right
um
but um that is um that is a very
um active um
you know area of research in itself um
another thing to like quickly point out
over here is that the the recording
equipment in itself also adds a lot of
bias to the
to the model itself so for example you
can you can you can train a model which
is which has just used your laptop's
microphone or um you know just just any
microphone um
at all and when you try to test it out
on a different microphone it will
you know even if you say the same exact
thing that that your training data has
and the same exact person says that it
could have different um results
altogether so this is like just the just
the noise itself and uh
you know how the overall audio is
constructed has like a major impact
um and and we're still like we're still
like trying to
um get ahead of this and like trying to
solve this this is like a very much
active area of research
thank you yeah it i know i did not
answer your question but
it was more of a rant
explanation of what's happening
it was great thank you you can go
perfect
um so let's let's dig deep into like how
this um
this entire clustering setup sort of
worked and uh you know how exactly did
they learn these um speech
representational units right
um so so
what they essentially did was they um
from the audio that was input to the
model
hubert essentially uses like a k-means
um clustering algorithm to
cluster these
speech units into 100 or so clusters
right
the the broad thought here is that um
uh similar sounding
um spoken units or similar sounding
snippets of the audio itself
would um cluster up together right um so
you know you would have something
um
um you would have something
um like you know on the on the top right
you'll have certain vowels on the top
left you will have certain consonants
and bottom right you will have something
else and and so on and um this could be
like clustered on uh multiple different
uh criterias um it could be based on the
pitch
or it could be based on like how
um
you know what is the duration of the
entire um spoken unit and and so on and
so forth but the idea is that you use
something uh as simple as k means to
cluster these together
um and and and then um
um you know mask these from the model
and then like ask the model
um what kind of spoken uh unit is it
right and then like um either either
periodize the mortal if it's wrong or
you know reward the model if it's if
it's if it's it's right um
not in like the not in the exact sense
but like essentially that's how the loss
calculation is um and and and you do
this like iteratively um through the
through throughout the pre-training
phase um so
um in the broader sense how this would
look like is that you have the audio
waveform and then we have the cnn
encoder which essentially which which
which first down samples the audio uh
and you know then it takes 25
millisecond snippets of the audio and
those become become your spoken
um or like speech representational units
then um you know 50 of them are masked
um and then
um they're they're essentially passed
through um
uh passed through the network and uh
simultaneously on the side there is also
this um this k-means-based um
acoustic unit discovery system which
performs the clustering on the side and
you know gives you
um certain representational units right
and then
the models task is to find what this
unit is sorry
uh to find what this unit is let me see
if there is a
yeah is to is is to find what this mass
unit is it does so by using like um
cross entropy loss um and and you know
uh we'll we'll get to the specifics in a
bit um but that's that's how the model
essentially learns so that's that's the
overall pre-training criteria which is
that um the model essentially has to
find what is the correct
um
representational unit for this
masked
speech unit
um cool before we
get too deep into the hubert framework
itself does um anyone want to chime in
and share their thoughts on on what
we've discussed so far
i just have a
basic question i guess
um
the 20 you said 25 millisecond
yeah
so that's from
and i'm no expert i'm learning um but
coming in so that waveform is
just
then dot split and then using that time
of 25 milliseconds to split it so it
could potentially split it in between
yeah a word kind of is that am i
thinking about it yeah yeah okay
um exactly so because there is no
um like from uh from the way um so first
of all i'm not sure if it's 25
milliseconds or if it's 20 milliseconds
it's one of those um but the way
um this kind of works is um that we
like there is no actual way of like
figuring out when a speech unit ends
yeah um and like if if there was an
actual way then we could just um you
know create a data set for it and and
like we won't need any of this
uh pre-training step uh at all like we
won't need clustering at all um in that
particular
uh um you know setup so because we don't
have it so um so we we just
give the model copious amounts of uh
amounts of data or like audio and uh we
hope that the model essentially learns
through like these partial speech units
and and even these like partial speech
units would sort of cluster together
because they will have similar
um you know uh characteristics um and
and um we sort of get to like how they
are similar
uh in just like one second um and and
then
um the similar ones sort of cluster
together and and then you can say that
hey this is this is one um you know unit
a or like
oh all of these speech units belong to
say the vowel
uh i or could be anything right and
then like the model um essentially
takes these these clusters and uh takes
whatever representation it it has from
the from the cnn um encoder and uh
checks um whether or not it is it is
correct about um the prediction of the
mask right
so that's the that's the sort of like 10
000 feet view of what's happening here
great thank you
perfect
um cool so um
let's sort of dig a little bit deeper
into the into the framework itself right
so there are like two things that are
that are happening simultaneously over
here so or or rather they're like two
steps that are
um that are um
um happening here so
the model
just takes the audio waveform as as an
input right and and and then it does
like two things um with it so um first
of all it takes the audio waveform and
uh directly sends it to the latent
feature encoder right this latent
feature encoder um i know it sounds kind
of like we you know kind of intimidating
but it's nothing but a convolutional
network right so it's just multiple
convolutional layers which are taking
the audio waveform and uh down sampling
the audio wave from from say you know
whatever 16 000 um you know uh rate to
um like it it down samples by 320 x but
that's not really important but it it
essentially down samples it and um
creates these like small
units
out of these these these units are
nothing but the but the representation
at the end of this um late in future
encoder right so um what is the 20
millisecond representation like let's
assume this is a hundred millisecond uh
waveform so there would be like five
like z1 z2 z3 z4 z5 like five sort of um
uh outputs from the latent feature
encoder and these are then then sort of
masked right so so their mask 50
of them are masked um
and they then are passed through the
context network
right and then the
the context network um
takes the representations or like um
takes these
masked representations and and um um
wait hold on let's let's uh not talk
about context network for a second um
let's just assume that we have like z1
to z5 um speech units from latent
feature encoder right parallely what's
happening is that these these audio
waveforms are then like transformed
using uh transformed and are um and and
we get their mfcc
um
representation um
uh from the waveform so we'll so so we
convert the waveform into numerical mfcc
representation which is then um sort of
split into
uh again those 20 milliseconds or 25
milli millisecond chunks and those are
then passed through like k means
clustering so um the thing that you see
over here so the um
these these features are then passed
through k-means clustering and then um
they're given like some sort of like a
hidden unit embedding right so
um so all the
for example like all of these are in
like one cluster all of these on like
another cluster and so on and so forth
so these these then get like some sort
of a unit embedding out of the
um out of the cluster so those can be
thought of as like cluster embeddings
right
and then these cluster embeddings
are
compared
with the output from the
um from the transformer encoder um from
the context network over here and um you
know we we essentially predict um
the the hidden unit at these mass
locations right
um and um um the way
like
the way learning actually happens here
is that if the model like like the loss
is only calculated on the mast locations
so not for all so uh so the loss is only
calculated for
um these
um
um mass locations right so this does two
things this one forces the the context
network um to create like
really strong representations for the
unmasked
um
for the unmasked
audio or like unmasked audio snippets
or like unmasked
snippets over here and
also of course learn to
you know find the most closest um
snippet that that that belongs to these
uh particular
um
representations right so
uh and and this keeps on happening right
so like um we do like step one which is
like we discovered these these hidden
units right um step two then we like
predict the
um the the targets at these mass uh
positions right and then we we we keep
doing this till the time we've sort of
um gone through the entire we've we've
done like one entire pass over the
entire data set so in the in in the
paper they pre-trained using the 960rs
libris speech data set um so like that's
the entire pass on the 960r library
speech um data set so um just to sum up
two things that are happening here we
take the waveform it goes through the
feature encoder right and then we get
um
our speech representational units on the
side parallelly we take the waveform we
convert it into um into mfcc features
and those are used for clustering um
which then gives us the hidden unit
embeddings and um
both of these uh like these hidden unit
embeddings are then used to predict um
what kind of target
should there be for these masked
positions
um
i'm gonna take a quick pause and see if
if
there's there's any um
if there are any points that anyone
wants to add on over here
cool i i think if i'm i would probably
ask a ask a question uh or or like
something which which did not really
make sense to me or um
something that i was i was i was kind of
thinking um in the paper they
um they sort of mentioned that
uh the way clustering works is like at
first they use these mfcc features
um
from the
um from the audio waveform itself right
and then they use it for like k-means
clustering
um at the at the first step right and
then um after the first clustering step
they
sort of
um lean into the intermediate
representation from the context network
itself to cluster further
right so so um essentially they they
they use the intermediate layer from the
previous step of the transformer over
here to cluster then um there on so like
the the bit that did not really make
sense to me was like why use the mfcc
features in the first place as the first
step of um of clustering when you can um
you know possibly take something like
wave to vector
to um
to you know create um or like create
these spoken
um
representational units um
if that question makes sense i would i
would love to have like a quick
discussion on that
that's
that's an interesting idea so you're
saying
you could um
like the first iteration instead of
using
these features you would use a trained
wave to vect model and and the like the
quantized
values that that model outputs you would
you would try and train this
yeah this network by
yeah
yeah and
i mean so my
my thought process over here is um
is mostly like
why why do we entire like why do we even
need this entire step right because this
is this just adds on to
the
the overall complexity like um why not
just
just start with like another like since
um
hubert like anyway sort of inherits so
much from wave to vector um in fact like
the entire code base is pretty much the
same um then like why not just just just
use the
already used units
from those from the
quantized layer of wave to a2 um
to then like cluster i i one i think
that those would be like
much more
um
uh you know
like like the overall signal in those
embeddings would be would be so much
more when compared to just like the ones
that you get from
mfcc features
i guess that sort of defeats the purpose
of of this different technique um for
the reasons you described before like
so to do that you have to have a wave to
back model that is trained and in order
to do that you you have to fiddle with
those um
the the gumball soft max parameters and
that just right
um so i guess if you yeah
i guess if you if you want to try a
whole new technique this this approach
with trying to bootstrap off of the mfcc
sort of classical
uh audio analysis approach makes sense
but um
i don't know i i i that that makes me
wonder like i guess there's other
not just wave to back but like other
audio models that could have useful
representations that you could also
bootstrap off of in the first iteration
but but then you you need
build off of their techniques which this
seems to be like i guess from the ground
up different approach here
yeah actually and and and just to just
think of that um one other point that
you
um like so um one reason why i
um
think that this this also might be a
good approach is this is also language
agnostic right so you don't need really
need like a like mfcc features would be
um kind of like
mscc features for like any language
right so they're not language dependent
whereas like a wave to work model would
be
language dependent or or say any spoken
language model or like spoken language
understanding model would be language
dependent at the end of the day uh even
if you take like the
the multilingual models or whatnot they
they still need to have enough
information about a particular language
um for uh for the model to
um do to give you anywhere reasonable
units whereas in this particular setup
you can you can
essentially do like cold start meaning
that the model does not know anything
and then through like first iteration
you just use mfcc features and then
um you you you hope that the models
learned enough about the the waveform
and then sort of default to
the context network as well
that's true yeah i guess if if the wave
to back model um was trained you know
for a particular language and reaches
some you know
particular performance
level then maybe like
there's limitations there and using
those representations um
maybe
like you can't get past whatever bias or
performance
that is achieved um
at the beginning and yeah like starting
from scratch with some like
less
more broad uh audio features um
useful but yeah i don't know
even so like it would be really
interesting to see if that technique
pans out
right yeah no uh um i agree um
um
um yeah just
just the whole like gaming like um like
like the first step like
once i've uh once i read the like
for the first time when i um read the
wave 2 uh paper i was like oh my god
this is such a complicated process but
like when you read the hubert uh paper
then they're just like yo this is not at
all uh complicated we just have like
we're just doing like simple k-means
clustering stuff so you know um that
just made me sort of think about like
the ways that you can even simplify this
further uh which would be to just like
use like a
separate model but um yeah
thanks for sharing your hearts
just on that on that topic that i was i
was more kind of confused by
the second iteration of like just
picking some layer inside the network
um
to then cluster off of
that just seemed like really
it was interesting i don't know if
that's used elsewhere to like
iterate on
putting
something from a model that comes from
the mod the same models like internal
layers in the previous iteration like
is is interesting i was surprised that
it worked so well
right and i think um
one of the reasons why
why it worked so well um and and like my
my intuition behind this was that um
because you're you're taking the
representations
um
from like one of the intermediate layers
meaning like these representations also
learn
while you're uh
while you're making the second pass at
the entire data set
like what that eventually
does um
in my opinion would be that uh since
since you're anywhere doing like masked
speech
representation over here so that gives
like another sort of signal for the
context net and the feature encoder to
uh create even better representation
right so because now the model knows
that hey for this particular
representation
um
you know i'm i'm
i am sort of um say 60 percent correct
um just just just just making this up
right now um and and then so uh and and
then the way um we sort of
uh do like when we do like another pass
at it then the then these um
representations from the context net uh
automatic like automatically would
become better because it's like feeding
off of that
if that makes sense
yeah yeah kinda i guess um
i don't i don't remember
exactly it seemed it seemed that like
the way that they picked that layer was
that it was highly correlated with um
maybe not correlated but they had some
other metric of like similarity with
um the
like uh
actual um
names or or text that they were trying
to
like the labels that they had for a
segment of the data set is that right
yeah they tried to pick like the out the
layer that was most correlated with that
text uh right labeling and that and that
makes sense feels a little like cheating
i guess but
it yeah it seems reasonable to do that
and then and then like you said like it
learns even better representations from
trying to predict that representation
and
right but i i
yeah i do agree that's kind of like a
meta move uh
literally
from them but yeah
yeah
um
perfect um so just um
i'm just gonna quickly just um ask
anyone else if if if if anyone else
wants to share their thoughts on the
whole discovery of um hidden units
through clustering
and um if you don't want to
unmute yourself you can also just like
go to the ml for audio study group and
just put on put down your question as
well i can
read it
over there out loud for for everyone as
well
um let's um
let's go like one step further uh into
like discovering these um hidden units
so
um
like this is essentially like what was
happening in the in the picture before
so like the first step is to extract
these like hidden uh units from the raw
waveform um of the audio itself right
then we have the k-means um clustering
algorithm which then takes each segment
and you know um assigns it to like one
of these uh one of the k clusters right
um and then we um
uh for for like each identified cluster
like each
cluster essentially becomes like a
hidden unit right and
all the audio waveforms within a cluster
um become part of that hidden unit right
um
and then like each hidden unit um within
the cluster
um
let's sorry each hidden unit which is
like one cluster is then mapped to like
another corresponding embedding vector
right and this embedding vector is then
used for um for the masked
uh language modeling process right
um so we essentially go from like
waveform like full full-fledged waveform
to 25 millisecond chunks from 25
millisecond chunks to
which cluster they belong to and from
cluster to um
another learned embedding of that
particular cluster right and then from
there we um like make predictions
and
once so so once this this um once we
have these like hidden units let's talk
about like how
do we actually um learn from the
um
like like
what's like let's look at the overall
prediction step or or the learning phase
of this right so we have um um from the
context net we have um
we have these randomly sorry from the
latent feature encoder we have these
randomly masked
representations these then like go
through the
the context um network right and then
they're they're sort of projected to be
at the same
um
to be for of to be at the same
same dimension as the
embeddings from the clustering step
right and then um you know we
essentially uh compute like cosine
similarity between the transformer
output and the hidden unit embedding um
to then like
um you know
find like which
which particular
unit
um should it be right so it's basically
a simple cosine similarity between um
all the hidden units from the clustering
step to uh to like whatever is the
projection after the final projection
step um and
um based on that they use like cross
entropy loss um
to then penalize wrong predictions and
uh the loss is only applied to the mast
position this is kind of important um as
and
the authors actually in like in within
the paper they they also show like
different um
experiments
with this so say for example like like
the first uh experiment they
uh tried was to calculate the loss on on
all the um outputs from the context
network so masked or unmasked doesn't
really matter they uh calculate um the
loss for for all of them then they just
did it for must just did it for like uh
unmasked and they found that that
just calculating the loss on the mast
positions um gave the best results
um
and
so on um and my explanation or like my
intuition behind um or like my
understanding of that was that this
forces the model to create
um even better
you know unmasked
representations so that um we're more
closer to finding the
um
the mast units
so i know i said a lot right now i'm
just gonna take a quick step back and
see if we have any um
thoughts comments
on this
perfect um so let's let's move forward
and let's see um what happens um next
right so now um we
with
so just a quick recap what we've
seen so far is that one hubert pretty
much utilizes the same
um sort of
architecture as we have to work to
um and
the thing that's that that's kind of
changed over here is the is the
pre-training objective so
um
um in case of hubert we have like a
clustering step whereas in case of wave
to vector we had um some sort of a
quantization step right and even like if
you uh compare the loss functions
between
the um
wave to vector architecture and hubert
architecture uh then um the the hubert
loss is significantly
uh more simplified um wave 2 use uses
like a combination of diversity loss and
uh contrastive loss
um
and uh you know
that's just a little too complicated
whereas um hubert essentially just uses
a very simple cross entropy loss only on
mast positions um
and
they basically do like two iterations
for like clustering so so the first one
first titration is done using the mfcc
features and the second iteration is
done um through the
transformer
embeddings
from the model itself um i think
if anyone's really interested in like
which
which particular layer they use so for
the base cubert model they use the sixth
layer
of the
uh of the
um feature um encoder
if i'm not wrong and for the for the for
the larger ones they use the ninth layer
and
they also did like an analysis as i
think someone mentioned before uh about
um you know which layer um gives the
best possible
results
right and and and that's that's that's
that's pretty much it right so the model
effectively like learns
these units and um um
uh they pre-trained it on on on libra's
ph 960r
like the full data set and
then they sort of tried this out for um
for
different
fine tuning tasks
for different downstream tasks sorry um
and
now that we've spoken about like
pre-training uh and like the training
overall let's talk about like fine
tuning of this so the fine tuning is
also pretty much the same as like beef
2x2 um so they um they take the
convolutional waveform audio encoder and
um you know those parameters are fixed
um
similar to wave 2.0 they have like a
free step hyper parameter which which
essentially freezes the
um the audio encoder for like certain
number of steps so this could be um i
don't know like
um one epoch of your like how seven
number of steps that you have for like
one epoch and so on and so forth i
didn't have like any specific
um
um
reasoning uh or like any specific table
about like what should be the
um the number here and uh you know then
you essentially train the soft max
matrix um
with like ctc loss for asr
um and uh like any other downstream
tasks that you may have so for example
you you can do like spoken language
understanding which is um classification
or like audio classification and you
know audio regression so on and so forth
um pretty much anything with the train
network then um so pretty much the same
as wave to back 2.0
um
i'm going to quickly like um zoom
through the
zoom through the
the resources and then we we can take a
quick um discussion break and then and
and see like um what thoughts everyone
has
um on it
um so um
i think one of the things which i really
like doing especially when i uh read um
like asr specific papers is to like look
at the results on like uh on on like low
resource meaning that when you just give
them uh give the model very few you know
very few data points and expect it to
learn so
the first one is the
is the 10 minute subset of the libra
speech data set um so you can see that
hubert
essentially
like outperforms um wave to vector
in pretty much
um
all the cases
um from what i can see
and um they tried with both a
transformer language model to um to
decode as well as just the four ram
model um as well
um
within like one r you can you can also
see like considerable difference between
i'm just comparing we have to make 2.0
large and hubert x large
um so this is 2.6
this is 4.8 this is 5.8 i think another
thing um
to mention here is that um
uh that hubert x large is like a billion
parameter model um
whereas i think it's it's it's a bigger
model than we have to wait 2.0 large i'm
not 100 sure on that if anyone remembers
that then uh please feel free to chime
in and and uh
um tell us about that um but yeah um
yes i think you're right uh vape to it
just three nine uh 350
yeah so um so so so then like hubert x
charge is not a fair comparison with uh
wave to a 2.0 large then um
yeah so if we if we compare just wave to
a 2.0 large with hubert large uh
transformer then
um i mean there is some
uh benefit for sure like 2.6 4.9 2.9 um
and we're comparing so we're comparing
with this one so 2.9 and uh you know
5.85.4 so not that much uh
you know improvement but it's definitely
an improvement and also like a
significantly simpler
uh training objective right so um
meaning that you can quite easily
uh
uh
go through and like create a hubert
model for
uh or like pre-trainer hubert model as
opposed to
you know when it comes to like a wave to
a 2.0 model wherein you have to like be
really really
um um cautious about like what kind of
parameters you're you're pre-training it
on
um similarly if you look at 10r um label
data so
for like hubert large um that's two
point two four point three two point
four four point six
um whereas over here two point four four
point eight uh two point six and 4.9 so
um again um slightly better than wave to
way 2.0 and um the same the same thing
for like 100
um
label data as well
um for like the full 960r um
data set we can see that
um
hubert large
is essentially at 1.5 3.0
um 1.9 and 3.3
um whereas vape to wick 2.0 large is
something at 1.6 3.0
uh 1.8 um this is actually lower than uh
hubert large and 3.3 so um when you have
like enough data then then both the
well when you give it like as much data
as possible then then both the models
kind of perform the same
um so i'm going to take
now like a quick pause and and see if we
have any um thoughts comments feedback
on this
yes i have a thought about or just a
question about um i'm back to maybe a
little bit what we were talking about
with with the input features um
model like using mfcc i'm not super
familiar with that i don't know if
anyone here has more of an audio
background and wants to comment on like
why that would be a useful thing to
learn from um as opposed to
like regular spectrogram
output or
uh i don't know what what other uh else
there is out there to to like learn from
but um why why that i'm not sure if they
commented on that on in the paper
great just just want to check if if
anyone wants to take that
yes i think the benefit of
mfcc's is that the frequency is on a
perceivable scale
right so
uh when you have the normal spectrogram
of power spectrogram the frequencies are
uh uh i mean in hertz okay and that is
not in a perceivable scale like uh
the features do not make sense visually
uh to you and uh
so
the way humans perceive frequency is on
the log scale right in the pitch scale
right so that is why uh
uh there is another scale called male
scale so there is a conversion
that goes from the normal frequency
scale to the mel scale so there is a
whole process for that the advantage for
that is in the mel scale uh the
difference between the two frequencies
uh
let's say if you have if you're
considering a normal scale okay and
uh the difference at the higher
frequencies will
actually uh appear more to you than the
lower frequency so let's say if you have
something at 18 kilohertz and 19
kilohertz right and then you have
something at six gigahertz and seven
kilohertz so the difference between both
the ranges is one kilohertz but the
sound will uh
i mean the sound will be very very
different to you the features would be
very very different to you uh even the
difference between both the ranges is
just one kilohertz but in the middle
scale this is not the case uh i mean uh
the difference between any two uh scales
uh you'll see that it will have a
constant uh
spectrogram or constant energy
the rate affections and compressions
that we say on the spectrogram so
that is a more perceivable scale in my
opinion i think uh if i'm not confused
you know
so
it makes sense so so the idea is to kind
of focus the features
from the audio based on what
uh human hearing and
the audible range is
yes absolutely and we are just changing
the scale of the frequency here to a
more perceivable skill which makes more
sense to actually visualize the features
and understand the spread so even if you
want to actually understand the spectrum
we visually write if you have a sentence
then you can actually go ahead and do
that by just uh
plotting it on the scaling you can see
the reflection and the questions in the
sound and understand that how different
syllables are announced
see
so so if we were to use this
architecture for a different audio task
like say bird song recognition or
something like that you know it wasn't
like audio from human
or um i don't know like uh
so some other audio tasks involving some
other kinds of sounds it might not make
sense to focus
using mfcc to scale it based on human
perception and rather like
ever domain
yes yes because uh the uh i think the
bird frequency is at a much higher scale
than what a human can perceive right so
i think our maximum hearing range is 20
kilohertz while the birds uh have the uh
is i think in the range of 44 kilohertz
to
50 kilohertz right so then it doesn't
make sense to actually bring down into
the spectrum but still i think those
techniques still work uh but they will
not work as efficiently as you as you
can work on the raw signal right like
wave to work doesn't converts the
audio into spectrograms it works on the
raw signal right so so if you have a if
you're trying to do a bird
classification or a bird identification
then i think working on the raw signal
uh makes much more sense because you do
not want to lose more information by
plotting it on a spectrogram scale
that makes sense and then what what
about using mel scale
spectrograms as opposed to m of cc
features like
the reasoning there is just i guess
fewer numbers
yes absolutely so mel scale is one thing
and mfcc is just the discrete cosine
transformations of the mel scale
basically so you have i think 13 uh uh
13
levels in the mel scale
level one level two level three and uh
it can actually classify that the sound
that you're trying to actually visualize
it appears in quartz mil scale right so
if in the case of a pert frequency it
could be in a higher middle scale let's
say and if in it's like a whisper or
something it would be a lower mel scale
so so it's all about the visualization
like how the humans perceive the
frequency and or the pitch basically
right and just to just to add on
sorry um about the
um whole mfcc thing so
um uh like i think
um one of the key things over here is
that the way that we hear things or that
the way we we perceive things is uh
because of these like really
infinitesimally small like hairs on our
on our ear um right and like those those
those hair are kind of like equally
spaced and that's the reason why like
mel
uh filter bank um works so metal
filter bank uh is um
like it it takes um
like the whole like linear um
you know um linear sort of audio form
and um the whole mfcc process um
sort of takes the continuous input and
like uh gives you a discrete
representation of it right because you
can't really process like continuous uh
waveform um generally right so it gives
you a discrete representation of that
and uh
since it is um really close to how we
perceive audio we meaning humans um
it is like really useful for
speech recognition or like spoken
language understanding tasks um and so
on and so forth so in most like uh up
until like up before the
the whole like transformer revolution
you would you would pretty much just use
the
the mfcc representation in fact right
now as well directly
and you know train some sort of a dnn uh
on those representations um for your um
downstream tasks uh as well
so
just wanted to highlight that
well yeah that was that was going to be
my other question about just like
has there been work on just instead of
trying to learn
good representations like from mfcc can
you just use mfcc and then learn
something on top of that but i guess
that's more of a
classical approach
right
yeah
and you lose things from the signal as
opposed to this approach which
in the end just takes the raw audio and
doesn't use any kind of
spectrogram
analysis before
it goes into the uh the convolutional
error to extract features which yeah
seems like it could extract much richer
features for the task yeah i think i
think one of the most uh more important
things over here is that like mfcc
representation and it's in itself is
like very
um like especially non-normalized ones
are like very uh prone to um
get swayed away if i may call it uh by
noise right so like if if there's like
noise in your audio signal then like
mfcc representations would
would not be as effective as like a
clear
audios mfcc
representation
and
you know when you use
when you directly model audio waveforms
then
you would you would assume or like you
would hope rather i'm just using the
word hope here that through your uh
feature encoder like through the
convolutions the model learns to sort of
avoid or like distinguish between noise
and signal right um so you're like
learning how you understand the signal
in itself as well in that case whereas
in like mfcc though
the representation the learning the
representation part remains like static
right which is mathematical so yeah
see it makes sense
yes so just to add to what web offset so
uh in
in any kind of smell spectrogram you
actually lose some information right
because you're trying to let's say if
your the audio sample rate is like 16
000 hertz right so it means you have 16
000 sample
samples in a second right and if you go
from that point to a spectrogram you
lose a lot of energy so and uh you use a
lot of information uh i mean not
information but a lot of certain things
that can be useful for the model right
it would be tougher to train the uh
model on the original signal
because there are more samples in the
original signal but in the end it would
uh it is expected to perform much better
on the original one if you train it in a
better way but in the past
as we discussed hiking end-to-end
architectures as well like in deep
speeches which was a crn type of
architecture we actually converted the
audio to a spectroglobe and then
the spectrogram was fed to convolutional
layers and then you had a lstmr on top
of that to do the speech recognition
task
hang on
um
perfect um so there's there's a there's
a question in the chat um maybe we can
spend like a minute
discussing that um what are the
advantages of hubert over wave to wick
if both have almost the same performance
so i'm gonna take a quick stab at it and
you know feel free to unmute yourself to
discuss this further um i think like one
of the major reasons why um
someone would prefer to you say hubert
over wave 2.2 is is uh specifically for
like from scratch like when you're
dealing with from scratch training right
so like when you're say for example
dealing with a new language altogether
um and uh you're like you're like
training from
um from scratch then you know um the
whole like pre-training process within
um
uh hubert is significantly more simpler
um as compared to um you know all the
billion things that you have to take
care of in a wave toward 2.0 and um i
have like limited experience like uh
pre-training vp it was um at least in
like the six seven times that i tried to
do that it was just
not performing that well so
um there's it's just way too sensitive
to the to the hyper parameters um and uh
uh what whilst i haven't uh tried with
with hubert um so far it it just the
entire approach looks significantly more
um
simpler when compared to wave to bit 2.0
um that was my quick thought um i'm
curious to see if if anyone else has any
thoughts on this
yes so uh
sorry i'm speaking to too much uh
i just wanna
yeah so just want to share i mean when
you uh when you're actually reading the
hubert paper and the way to
paper they're actually comparing the
results on the speech recognition task
right and seeing results you might say
that hubert is good but uh nobody uses i
mean i'm not seeing anybody uh using
hubert in the production system or
something so that is first thing but
that's for the speech recognition for
other tasks like uh speech separation
speaker questioning or let's say speaker
identification
uber tends to perform much better than
work in those tasks i mean this is my
personal uh
finding right so basically if you have a
if you're doing a speaker clustering
task or something else then as compared
to wave to wake i hope it performs much
better uh even but even on speech
relation it performs better but what we
found out that uh it was not very uh
better in terms of when you have
different speakers i mean all together
different directs than the training data
right so i just want to give you an
example like in india there are like
different regions right so if you have
collected
data from the north
if you've collected data from the north
region and then you're trying your model
out on a person who has a south indian
accent right then hoover doesn't tend to
perform much better in that case uh we
don't know what is the reason maybe the
reason is somewhere the information is
lost or something but wave to work
adapts more to directs and noise uh in
the speech recognition but for speaker
clustering uh source separation and
speech separation for other tasks hubert
forms much much better than we're doing
but i think just just uh
that was actually a brilliant point and
uh
i'm not sure if
we have seen this here um but there's
this um like um once the the author sort
of looked through the
um the output of
um or like how how accurate the speech
units um were within uh
oh
is there someone who wants to say
something
never mind um yeah once they looked at
the um the
um the overall like spoken language
units like um
learned by the model um they were
actually able to create um like a
generative model uh at the end
uh
let me see if i can find
the link to it
um
was it this one
so that's um so
that basically paves way for like text
less nlp um
and
[Music]
sorry this is this is still like loading
um
but um but the but the but the idea here
is that since the since the
hubet model like essentially learns um
how
um
the waveform in itself or like speech in
itself is um
is
is created or like what it's made up of
um you can you can use it as a
generative model in you know and you
don't need like any any sort of
um
text for it and this is like um another
like
uh active area
um of research that i think they've been
focusing on uh quite a lot um of late so
you can like directly just use um
the
the representations from um
from the model so uh just to like um uh
double down on like harveen's point um
these uh like these representations in
itself are like really really um
good right when when when when compared
to say we have to wake two so these like
inner representations are are fantastic
so that's why they they perform quite
well on like spoken language
understanding tasks and
um
so on and so forth just wanted to
quickly point it out
perfect um so maybe we we quickly head
over to like the conclusion and then we
can um you know spend the last 15
minutes um having some sort of a
discussion um about the overall paper
and you know if anyone has any questions
we can take those as well
um
by the way thank you for sticking on for
so long i know it's been like an hour uh
since we've been talking um but cool so
um in the end like um the paper presents
like a really fantastic um way and like
a simplified way of like learning the
um the individual units um that
constitute um
you know speech uh using like k-means um
and uh you know they also learned that
um
you know i iterating through these like
cluster assignments um through like um
already learned late representations
also helps so this is pointing to the
fact that after the first iteration of
k-means um the clustering algorithm um
effectively takes the
um the representation from the
previously learned model right so this
is the sixth layer of the um
of the model um and uh they also
were able to scale hubert quite quite a
lot so they were able to scale hubert to
like a one billion uh parameter
transformer model as opposed to like in
case of wave 2.2 they were only able to
scale it up to uh 390 million uh
parameters if i'm um not wrong and um uh
it just means that like the the
potential to
um to learn or or like the potential for
like bigger models using hubert um
is much higher
um as compared to the other one right um
and and like in the end um they found
that the the representations are were
off like really high quality and uh you
know uh that's why like hubert uh in
itself can be used for like downstream
tasks beyond just recognition and can be
used for like generation tasks can be
used for like understanding tasks and so
on and so forth
um
as well so just a
quick thing if you're if if if you found
hubert to be like really interesting you
can you can of course try out like um
there are i think as of this morning
there were roughly about 120 hubert
models for different languages as well
as like all the
x large large
base um models that um small and base
models that the authors released are on
the hugging face hub so you can of
course just
go over there and try out a quick
pipeline to see um
how hubert works and you know you can
also put a hubert model against a wave 2
model for certain um complex um
synthesis or just like classification
tasks to see how well it does
i've linked this and
the
presentation is linked in the
ml for audio study group channel as well
um perfect which this now brings us to
the end of the act and you know paper
reading per se um i think it's it's a
good time to open
um
the overall channel for discussions and
you know questions if we have any
so i think um maybe i'll i'll just put a
question up for um for discussion
and um
this was something which was like
bugging me when i was uh reading the
paper um was that there's like so if you
look at like um wave 2 there is an xlsr
model which which which was sort of
pre-trained on like multiple languages
and so on and so forth uh but there
wasn't
like there at least to my knowledge
there isn't any like multilingual hubert
model so i was just like wondering um
if this is something if if one anyone
has has heard of
um a multilingual hubert model and two
if uh
if not then what might be the reasons
for
a multilingual
multilingual hubert model not existing
maybe they were saving it for the next
paper
i don't know
i'm
i'd i'd also be curious i don't know why
that's interesting
yeah it's just um it just didn't
make sense to me i'm actually also not
sure like how the pre-training worked
for like multiple languages in uh xlsr
model um i'm not sure if if it was done
like iteratively
uh language by language or it was just
like mishmash all languages and you
learned like all the hidden
representations
uh in one go um so i'm not sure if if if
anyone remembers from xlsr paper then
feel free to chime in
now it's uh i think it's actually all
the languages in one go what they try to
do is that in a batch they try to
include all the languages
in in one bad uh sorry in one batch i
mean one a transfer of all the language
the only i think the condition is that
if you're feeding just one
what do you say one audio chunk right so
that has to be in one particular
language so it cannot be in multiple uh
languages but again i mean it's quite
flexible okay so we have done like uh at
my work we have done like pre-training
for 23 indic languages using ten
thousand dollars of data right
and uh we didn't try all of these things
like to keep all the languages in one
batch or so but at the end of the day we
get a good model uh with improved
accuracy on the indic languages and so
so it's basically you just create a
bunch of data and then just give it to
the model and let it figure it out on
its own
right i think that that that might
actually be the reason right so um
what's what's happening in the wave to
vector
model is that you you have this entire
quantization matrix which is which is a
learned parameter so to speak right
um
whereas in the case of uh
you know hubert um
like there is no like quantization
matrix right there is just like a
k-means clustering uh
uh thing uh well algorithm nothing
and uh
i'm assuming like when you when when you
have like multiple
uh languages one your number of hidden
units increase um because when you have
more
uh
units now uh more possible units um so
one that and um i'm just not sure like
um if it will scale well for like you
know languages which are similar
sounding
um so so you know especially in case of
say for example indic languages they can
be like really similar in the way that
uh certain
things are pronounced or like certain
units are pronounced and they might like
glub into like a single unit and that
might just like confuse the model
further because like the clustering part
is not really learned so to speak right
um the the representation is learned um
so maybe i'm just like throwing out
ideas right now
so i think the quantization module in
wave to work is just a similar thing uh
that we have as word vectors in nlp
right
so it's kind of a similar thing right so
if you have
a sound so basically computer doesn't
understand
language right it's our human brain that
actually understands that english is
different than hindi right so maybe
they're trying to say uh
say like if a word or a single name or
let's say for neem
is accompanied by this starting phoneme
ending for neem then maybe this is the
word vector for that so like in the case
it happens exactly in the casing hmms
right so you have a uh something in the
starting of name and the ending of the
phoneme and then you figure it out uh
this one belongs to which cluster right
and uh on the clustering part uh when we
actually fed all the languages to the
way to vector model and
there is an option to actually
uh
find the embeddings from the model and
then
using a tsne or something plot those
embeddings to see like which languages
are close to each other right and as you
rightly said i think the south indian
languages were really close to each
other then hindi punjabi and sanskrit
was really close to each other right so
which said that if you want to create a
good model for hindi
right then in the pre-training step you
can include languages of that of audio
of maybe hindi punjabi and sanskrit so
maybe you can train one model for one
cluster for better uh speech
representations right like create one uh
separate patron model for the only the
south indian languages like
[Music]
right right and then only for the north
indian languages like in the punjabi and
sanskrit right so yes that is surely
going to improve but uh this analysis
that we did uh was just uh when we fed
all the 23 languages in one go and then
we realize that if you need to create
better representations then maybe pick
clusters from here and do or do a
crystal wise training a pre-training
basically
right
right i think also like this might um
also tie into to the fact that this this
may just be why like you don't see like
hubert that much out there in
in production because
um
you you you would like it's it's not as
if um it's not as simple as as say just
like we have to wait to when
everything's being learned um
on the fly
um you you you actually need quite a lot
of data for um
for the model especially for like asr um
you know specific tasks the model needs
to sort of learn
um
um you know um
those units so so especially for like
low resource languages um it might just
not be that um
scalable
then
and and you know that's why we don't see
it uh that much out in the world
yes
yes so so i actually visualize this
thing as like uh the output of the
transformer right
in the case of nlp the output of the
transformer has to be one of the
characters from the vocabulary right
which is limited right right so but the
sound doesn't have any vocabulary right
so it builds the vocabulary on the fly
so what is the vocabulary the
quantization code books are the
vocabulary basically so i visualize it
like this way right so the vocabulary is
built on the fly based on what input do
you give to the model
right
now that's that's actually brilliant and
and
um and also like in in in case of wave
2.2 these these code books are learned
so these these codes are nothing but
like represent like are just like
matrices right
um i i i think that's um that actually
might sum up why there is no
multilingual um hubert
um
yeah but we need to find a concrete
answer for that
maybe
yeah yeah for sure um i think it might
be worth tweeting this out after this
to see
if anyone has any questions
nice um so
um
i'm just gonna uh maybe like we use the
last nine minutes to see if
if anyone else has any other discussion
points or like questions that they want
to
um discuss um otherwise we can call it a
day
i have a list a question
yeah concerning the uh
the uh
the hardware uh sorry i wasn't uh able
to join you in the beginning so i wasn't
uh i haven't seen all the your
explanation about hubert but what do you
think about uh
like uh performance in the uh in the uh
uh uh hardware perspective uh of hubert
against wavetovic for example if you
have a constraint of of uh of hardware
like for example if we just want to use
cpu or or or like maybe we just want to
use jsons or something like that
with a
limited amount of power what
what do you think uh like the difference
between your birds and wave to it
well i can i can i can take a quick stab
at it so if you um and maybe i can just
um open this right now right so if you
just look
at the
um at least on like hugging face if you
just look at the
um the code base for uh hubert um on
transformers um
library it's pretty much exactly the
same as uh wave to wake right
um the only thing that changes is like
what
what model you're um
essentially um
sort of using at the end of the day so
to speak right so uh in terms of i think
in terms of just like sheer say
inference i i think the performance
would be
pretty much the same uh for like
for like hubert all the way up to like
large models so and then and i'm just
talking about like inference time right
now for like resource constrained
environments i think it should be same
because um
the overall network is pretty much the
same minus the pre-training step right
which doesn't really matter that much
for inference um so to speak right um
whereas when it comes to say for example
training um
i i think you would um it's it's safe to
assume that
while training
wave to a 2.0 model would take um you
know
longer because it's it's sort of
learning
um everything
in itself um as compared to say a hubert
model right uh in purely in terms of
like training time when you compare like
um you know the same hardware or like
the same
um uh
uh setup um so um those two are the
things which which i think uh
might be relevant here
um but i i
maybe we just open this up to everyone
who's on here and if they have any
thoughts on this
yeah okay for your thank you for your
explanation
right and and this is what i was i don't
know if you can see my screen with
um
the code base like like a lot of stuff
is just like inherently like taken from
wave 2 model so and in fact in their
paper as well they just mentioned that
they take the same sort of feature
encoder the same sort of context network
um and then like the only thing changes
is the
clustering step um
over there
does hugging face um show
inference performance
statistics like uh
about models um
and the hosted models in particular i
guess like
when they're executed
i think there's like memory or constant
yeah i'm i'm not sure if if there is um
anything um exactly like specific to
um
[Music]
um you know um
finding like how accurate or like how
much time does the model take but i
think just just from like finding how
much inference time a model would take
is is that you can just like record from
the
um
browser let me just quickly see
um hello
and
if i compute then i think it it gives
you like some sort of like seconds taken
or like
um time taken to
um
uh to infer so that might be the only
thing that that i think hugging face
provides at the moment
yeah
at least on the on the model cards
okay cool
it'd be kind of interesting to have that
in model cards i don't know future
request here
i'm not sure if
homer's on the call here
but i would let him know for sure
yeah actually the speech recognition is
good but to train models you need a lot
of hardware right
both in case of wave to it too and uh
uber right and even the hubert paper
they mentioned that they're using 32
gpus to train it uh basically and but
hubert uh trains faster than vip2vic2 i
mean what
from the visual paper that they have
published right and uh like they're
using uh
i think 256 gpus for the hubert xl x
large
right and i don't think we can ever
afford to have this kind of uh stuff
here with us for the pre-training and
all right so
uh
the speech pre-training is kind of
pretty pretty expensive
right i
yeah i mean i i i do agree with you um
on that um and and and uh i mean um
uh it would have been like really cool
if like um you know we had like hubert
like sort of uh multilingual models um
precisely for the same reason because
then you can like even like well fine
tuning would pretty much be still the
same uh as like wave two went to um but
um you know um
specifically for like from scratch
training for like
low resource languages like
um you know
one of the like main demerits that that
that this particular model has in my
eyes is that it can pretty much never be
used for like
um
you know low resource languages um
at all right um i know i i started off
with something and like ended with
something but uh i just wanted to sort
of have that out that you know like like
um irrespective of how simpler the model
is um it's it's just it's just something
that that requires is it you know a lot
of data for it to work
um well
unless of course like someone tries to
figure out the whole um you know
clustering step and like augments that
with like some other
um you know like a wave to vector uh
esque model
uh to sort of create those like units um
and so on but i'm assuming that'll just
become even more complicated as we go
further but yeah
great um i think i think this was um
this was fantastic um and just in like
interest of time um i think we should we
should call it a day now but if if
anyone has any other questions uh feel
free to drop by
um ml for audio study group channel and
you know put your questions there um and
you know um
we'll we'll make sure to get those
answered um as soon as possible um and
you know thank you so much for joining
us this was a lovely discussion in my
opinion and i will also share the slides
again
and push those on the github repo that
we have um
thank you so much and um hopefully we'll
catch up in couple of weeks for another
paper
thank you
thanks
thanks a lot
all right
you